I mean last time I was here was awesome
we had a really good time and then since
since I've been here
Paul can you play the clip please oh
wait wait wait hold it oh there's a clip
split clip you mean from Hard Knocks
let's play the clip ball two days hit
squad is lost a few more good as dudes
where nice guys we do the right thing on
the field when you step on the field
you're the baddest on the planet and
together we're the baddest and team on
the planet and that's the way we're
gonna attack okay you came at me hard
this year Dan now now there's something
else you are here we go here we go it's
like you're on a roller coaster with
your kid on swings whoo yeah off the
field we're good dudes yep on we're
gonna help old business we gotta pay our
taxes on time we're gonna eat all the
vegetables three square meals a day
hospitals go to church and we're buying
Girl Scout cookies you have to hear me
eight hours sleep okay okay I understand
why you might have a problem with us but
it's it's great to happen see you though
it's good had you not heard that you're
a good effin dude you had not heard that
no you think I watch your show Dan
well that's HBO that's hard enough no I
yeah I didn't watch the show you did not
know I lived it it was terrible
well I warned you that you do you sure I
want to do it
you could have just said they came and
asked me then well you could have said I
don't want to be in it couldn't you no
you can't say that you can't sold
the whole team yeah but you're the star
the team they over obviously they're
gonna put focus on you they should have
you should have said look I'll give you
a lot of times where I said you're not
allowed to fill me really yeah I was
only I think we only allowed him to put
a microphone on me like once every three
days or something like that because
obviously they you want every day and
that's the one we had fun with oh yeah
yeah but did you hear from your parents
like not language once so this is how it
happens so I gave gave that speech I
turned around and walk out of the huddle
and I was like cuz I saw the camera here
so I literally went back to my locker
texted my mom I said I'm just gonna let
you know it's gonna be it's gonna be a
little interesting this week on hard
knocks and they don't actually bleep it
out on the show do they it's they say
they let it fly uh yeah I think they did
I pawned a bleep a lot of it out like
it's over the top okay yeah that was
over the top I'll take that one uh
you're the only guest I will ask the
following ok
how's your groin that's it's doing all
right it's doing but have you had
surgery before any other place no that's
your first surgery my first thing ok so
I was gonna see if you could compare
that with a knee or shoulder or some
yeah do you have to take a sharpie and
Mark which side of the groin like when
you do knee surgery right right they
give me a sharpie and I had mark my knee
right no I I have both sides done
Oh boom I had a lot done I have actually
have six incisions so yeah there's a lot
a lot going on down there and you head's
not good down there right now it is not
good I'm just going to tell us show us
show us your effing groin let's go now
it ended up being a bit more extensive
than we planned originally so there was
there was more wrong than we thought and
it turned out to be but you know I have
great people taking care of me so
they're doing a really good job and you
had a lot of nurses who volunteer help
you incredible amount of that's nice yes
did you realize how many qualified
health care providers are it is it is
awesome whether we're they're gonna be
house calls here that's what it sounds
like it sounds like house calls late
telecoms without money if you need a
groin massage guys just go to my Twitter
feed
there's people offering them up left
there you go Fritzi right up you don't
even have a bad groin all right
so what's going on it's it's been it's
been fun been crazy been a little goofy
here have you we did you see Blake
bortles Reid I don't profile I did okay
yes we loved and printed out now just so
you know these aren't ours these were
actual Scouts who wrote this about you
okay so right before the draft read your
your profile JJ wants okay won't
consistently get the edge on tackles
with his get off or quickness whoops
that's some slow plays high at times can
be blown off the ball by a double team
but does fight hard to hold his grunt I
do fight hard to hold my ground okay all
right that's a black Santa coming yeah
lack some lateral mobility both rushing
the passer and playing in space read the
one on the bun his recognition skills
leave something to be desired I think
they just called you dumb as well yeah
that's me that's a knock he flashes good
hand usage at times but needs to get
stronger at the point of a 22 get
stronger
oh my god I'm entering the a concussion
protein in here he needs to gain some
more weight to fill out and to continue
to learn how to use his hands
effectively can you imagine what I could
do if I learned how to use my hands
effectively he won't ever be a stud pass
rusher
that was awaiting you I only wish I
could be one eye only but he could still
stand to learn some pass-rush moves
beyond his bulrush an occasional swim to
the inside if a tackle opens us who
wrote this Pauly do you know who wrote
about he'll never be a good you want me
to bring him out if he was in the back
with this that would be offensive
I'll get the name for you I could learn
I need to learn man I need to learn some
things Dan but the perception and
reality though with with the draft and
trying to prove yourself right I think
it was their stereotype going in of of
you yeah you know the steroid everybody
here so you were high motor I was a high
motor guy I was worked hard in rat yeah
work sorry student of the game
oh not overly athletic but will grind it
out that's just the way it goes and and
you know I can understand why people
talk like that because you got hundreds
and hundreds of prospects you have to
talk about and people want to read about
but at the end of the day you can't you
can't peg every single guy and try and
act like you know what he's gonna be or
how he's gonna be who was gonna draft
you in your mind I I had thought that I
would go anywhere from the Cowboys at
number 9 to the Chargers or the Patriots
that I think like 17 18 that was kind of
the range that I had thought in my mind
but when you said your parents where
they probably asked you who do you
thinks gonna draft you I said the
Chargers and I think they were number 17
or 18 so when your name got called what
did you know about well what so what
happened what happened when I got
drafted it was kind of a cool moment
because I've been training out in
Arizona with guys and Blaine Gabbert was
one of the guys I trained with and he
got picked tenth right before me and the
Jacksonville picked him and so I went
over I walked over to his table and I
congratulate him said good job my agent
talked to me on the shirt and he said
hey you might want to sit down and so I
went over sat down the phone rang in
Texans drafted me and if you'd asked me
before the draft who I thought would
draft me the Texans would have been 30
or 31 32
but do they hide it they huh
so my defensive line coach was bill
kohler with the Texans and he was the
one so you meet with people at the
combine
and I met with bill colar at the combine
just in passing in the train station in
Indy and he come up to me he goes you
think you play hard don't you and I was
like well yeah I got a pretty hard he
goes I'm gonna tell you right now you're
one of the laziest players I've ever
seen and I was like well I'm not going
to use in Texas so he's he's telling
that how do you process that where
you're saying okay this guy just got my
face and said right well you're so
you're trying to think in your head
you're like okay they taught me some of
these draft things and and these guys
are gonna try and get inside your head
so is there like am I supposed to answer
that some certain way or so I just I was
like no I think I play pretty hard but
we were the laziest player I have ever
seen what did you say to him or what did
he say to you when you got to Houston he
said remember what I told you at the
combine I said yeah he said I'm gonna
get that out of you he still thought you
were oh yeah but then as the years so
for my first year in the league I
couldn't stand the guy like I we like
but it has and I really didn't really
enjoy it at all but as the year went on
and as I got to know him and understand
what he was trying to do and how he was
trying to push me I loved the guy to
this day and we talked he's the coach of
the Broncos now but we talk almost
weekly he's an incredible guy I love him
to death and I really appreciate what he
did for me helped push me to an entirely
new level JJ is joining us on behalf of
Papa John's we'll talk about that
promotion when we come back also his
thoughts on Cam Newton people don't seem
to have a problem if JJ celebrates but
they do with Cam will we'll talk about
that also will talk about that cabin
that little small cabin yeah and that
little cabin you go to and you get you
rough it yeah style but yeah now he's
saying oh you guys are so rough on me
it's like a shark tank in here I'll just
keep it real your draft profile said
overly sensitive to criticism from radio
shows yeah well that's one area in my
game I haven't ironed out yet how do you
process criticism though now because you
I mean you've right
you're accomplished over the course of
my career it has completely changed I
used to take it very hard I used to read
everything every article everything and
see it all in over the course of the
last year and then especially over the
course of the last few months I've
really kind of taken on the role of I
really don't care what people say and it
it's almost difficult to do because
there's so much out there between
Twitter and and Facebook and all the
articles you read and everybody has an
opinion but I've just kind of gotten to
that point in my career where I'm like
you can't please everybody there's no
chance you're gonna make everybody happy
so just do whatever you want to do and
if people don't like it like with it but
you realize how this goes that you come
from you know you're discovered and then
you start to be built up and then you
get to a certain point and then start to
tear you down yeah absolutely
and it's not a it's not a very long time
time period and Cam Newton's realizing
this now yeah Steph Curry's gonna
realize there's no how are you gonna
have I mean you realize that's happening
now yeah so now it's your doing too many
commercials he celebrates his sacs right
I I it took me a while to get to the
point where I understood what was fully
happening because for a little while
there you don't really understand you're
like I'm doing everything I've always
done why are people just now starting to
have a problem with it but that's kind
of the way it goes you know there's it's
kind of like the rise people like to see
a guy succeed that they didn't think was
gonna succeed and they'd love to see the
rise but then once you get to the top
and more and more people start to like
you then people are like well I like
them first now I don't like him anymore
because he's changed well I haven't
changed a single bit I'm still the same
guy but more and more people like you
more and more people want to tear you
but it's like a band that when we find a
band and it's then they're ours sorry
and then they get big right then all of
a sudden we don't like them it right
yeah exactly so you're like up a hog man
how would you handle that then I would
do less if I were you okay I would
consciously say I'm gonna do less and
spread it out over a longer period of
time okay but but it's hard to pass it
up you don't know how much is too much
right and I'm sure you've passed up a
lot of opportunities yes I would you
know you have to pick wisely and how
often do the commercials run right
that's another thing because Peyton I
think people got turned off that Peyton
was doing all these commercials yeah so
I think that it's a delicate balance
there absolutely
he's incredibly delicate yeah and
there's a lot of different things at
play
you know people there's so many
different things that come along with
everything that happens that I don't
think people sometimes fully understand
all the different things that go into
what's with this life and I think that's
kind of why I've taken on that mentality
where I'm just gonna be me I'm gonna do
what I do and if people don't like it
they don't like it because I've noticed
that people don't like you even if
you're trying to even get to do
everything the right way so it doesn't
matter what way when you get criticized
for taking a picture with your
grandmother right yeah look at this guy
Wow Wow I bet he worked out right
afterwards no way he should be working
out not walking on ladies yeah seriously
guys talking about being a good guy at
all how dare he how dare he but no I
mean it's part of it and it's fun you
know passionate fans are fun and it's
it's good so I'm learning to live with
the punches but I I mean I'm not gonna
sit here and act like over the years
they're having pinpoints where I'm like
I don't I don't understand why these
people don't like me I don't understand
because I'm a human and it does it has
affected me yeah so you just learn to
live with it and now I really don't care
speaking of which you're joining us on
behalf of Papa John's right if you would
do you want me to do the plug here and
then you can fill in yeah absolutely
right so starting Monday following the
Super Bowl Papa John's the official
pizza sponsor of the NFL and Super Bowl
50 will launch its quality guarantee
Papa John's guaranteeing that you will
love your pizza if you don't you tell
them why and get another one absolutely
free go to papajohns.com slash guarantee
for more info also Monday following
Super Bowl 50 customers get one large
pizza up to 5-toppings for just $9.99
the quality guarantee it's tough to pass
up they believe in their product so much
that they're willing to tell you if you
don't like it at all you call us and
tell us why in the cold into another one
they can call you they cannot call me
they can not call me do an 8 inch ball
some Papa John's customers though that
is one thing I actually do enjoy so over
the last year we had this program in
Houston where 10% of every Tuesday's
sales in the Houston area went to my
charity and it was awesome
we raised almost $400,000 last year for
my charity is crazy but every
Tuesday there's one winner and so I get
to call that winner every Tuesday and
have a 5-10 minute conversation with
them and at the end of the year we had a
pizza party that was as awesome because
there were some stories where I'd call
person one week it's just a two minute
call saying thank you but then there was
one week where this person got the phone
call from me and they told me a story
about how they had just lost their
brother I believe was their brother to
cancer and this call was a pick me up
that they didn't see coming but they
absolutely needed and so you you fall
into these stories that you never even
realized were possible and so that
little phone call made that person's day
and kind of picked him up after a tough
situation so it was really cool I'm sure
you still got criticized for what you
workout for your next practice man uh
practice your speeches what why do we
have a problem where why do people
appear to have a problem with Cam Newton
maybe it's old or maybe it's a
generational thing that Cam Newton has
fun why why is that that all of a sudden
this is a topic I don't know I don't
understand it
I really don't understand it because
football is a game it's an entertainment
business football is fun it's supposed
to be fun at the end of the day people
pay money to go sit in the stands and
watch a product on the field that is
entertainment based so I don't
understand why a guy gets to the endzone
he celebrates with his teammates with
the fans how is that bad what's wrong
with that
the thing that cracks me up I was
talking about this earlier today is
people want to talk about act like
you've been there before just hand the
ball the ref and go to the sidelines do
you have any idea how hard it is to get
there I have been there before I know
how hard it is to get there so heck yeah
I'm gonna celebrate it's it's so darn
hard to score a touchdown or to get a
sack and in what I would say is if you
don't like it as a defensive player when
you get a sack on him you absolutely
have the right to either mock his dance
or do your own dance that's the way
football works it's a competition so if
you get the best of me you go celebrate
if I get the best of you I get to
celebrate that's just the way it works
that's competition you ever had a
problem with somebody celebrating well
you know against your team I mean of
course you don't like it but I don't I'm
not gonna
there's nothing wrong with celebrating I
don't I don't unless you're actively
berating or belittling another guy I
have no I don't think that celebrating
is a problem got a you know you picked
you care who wins the Super Bowl
I really don't but I think that I was
coached by Kubiak in his staff and coach
Phillips and obviously coach Cole are we
talked about and so I think that those
guys were incredible to me my first
couple years in the league so I think
would be awesome to see them get a title
under their belts just really good guys
coach Kubiak one of the best guys I've
ever met
did you get Peyton have I got a sack pin
yeah yeah I I have is that where he's
sort of seizure coming any falls down no
I got him a call you yeah I got him I
was I got him I think three times in
2012 so because if he comes back maybe
you could do this where you sack him and
you say special delivery from Papa
John's dude good I mean they're you
serious there you go what better I'm
just writing scripts here for you I mean
it's it's unbelievable so if you get Cam
Newton I think I mean maybe me and
Peyton would make a deal we're like hey
if I sack you I get one of your stores
Oh that'd be a good deal he's got a few
of them yeah so I think that'd be fine
have I gotten camera I got cameras here
yeah yeah now that go and went good just
quick were two big guys and we hit
pretty hard
there's I'm not gonna lie it was a
pretty hard hit is he now he doesn't
weigh more than you know he does not but
he's a big fella he's but he can move I
mean the guy he's an incredible athlete
there's no doubting you see bigger than
Roethlisberger I don't know I think I
don't you have to look at the stats
literally I don't know the answer but I
think Ben made maybe just a touch taller
but I don't know they're both very
difficult to bring down I miss in my
rookie year I had two wide open sacks on
Ben missed them both got out he was you
you whiffed on him absolutely that was
that was my rookie year and like my
first I think is like my fourth game
bill Pollard not a JJ Watt fan yeah no
he did not like that and Ben doesn't
move the east side he was yeah he didn't
move a whole lot
I just enough he ducked on one of them
and then the other one I think he like
half spun out but he got out and those
would have been my I believe those have
been my first two sacks in the league
I might have gotten I can't remember if
my first tag was before after that game
but yeah
Benghazi pretty good I like that JJ came
in and he had two things that he wanted
to accomplish smash seaton in the face
with a pie and also pour a pint of
Guinness Jobs drink it
that's not the end goal Dan okay so it's
a it's papajohns.com slash guarantee for
more information always great to see JJ
while Drew Brees will join us coming up
next if you want to go poor you I might
again as you can thank you this is the
Dan Patrick show